Fake X-Force scenes, a Chris Evans cameo,
underwater scenes with Vanessa, and not-safe-for-work
Disney jokes were all cut from Deadpool 2.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm explaining everything we never
got to see in the Deadpool sequel [plus details
on an extended cut of the movie.]
If this is your first time here, be sure to
subscribe to get all my Deadpool and Marvel
videos and leave a comment for a chance to
win some cool Deadpool 2 merch.
Spoilers ahead, of course, for the movie,
so take care if you've not seen it yet.
It was fun meeting the new X-Force team in
Deadpool 2 even though our time with them
was pretty short.
But if you'd watched the movie's trailers,
you probably thought we were going to get
more time with the new team than we did, including
action scenes with both Bedlam and Shatterstar.
And that's exactly what the filmmakers wanted
you to think!
Yes, the movie's director and writers told
Uproxx that they filmed those extra scenes
with the actors in front of a green screen
knowing full well that they'd never put them
in the final film.
It was all done with the aim of pranking the
audience, and at one point they were even
planning to make individual character posters
and standees of the X-Force members as well,
however, the Studio told them to hit the brakes
in case audiences got too annoyed when they
saw the film.
The idea behind the marketing, of course,
was to make all those sudden X-Force deaths
more of a shock to viewers watching the movie
in the cinema.
Which it certainly was though it was still
a bit of a shame to see so little of actors
like Terry Crews, Lewis Tan, and Bill Skarsgard.
There wasn't any explanation in the movie
about where Cable got his mutant powers or
his metal arm from.
However, there's a potential nod to his cybernetic
arm and the techno-organic virus from the
comics in a voiceover line in the trailer
that we never heard in the final film.
In the film, Cable asks Weasel:
"What's the most pain you've ever felt?"
But this next line from Cable in the trailer
was cut from the movie.
"Maybe the kind that leaves you more machine
than man."
Perhaps this audio was part of a deleted scene
or it could be an extended version of Cable's
monologue when he's interrogating Weasel.
And based on Cable's words, it sounds like
this would have added yet another Star Wars
easter egg to the movie, this time referencing
Obi Wan Kenobi's words about Darth Vader.
"He's more machine now than man."
As for Cable's rich comic-book history, the
movie's writers told Vulture that they used
the comics as guideposts while adding their
own spin on things, going more for the "tone
and feel" of a character than details and
plotlines.
And while the movie does feature some nods
to Cable's comic-book backstory, as I've talked
about in my Deadpool 2 easter eggs video,
the screenwriters made a conscious decision
not to go heavily into his background as they
felt it was too much information for a 2-hour
film.
It's interesting that earlier versions of
the script did include Cable's telekinetic
powers, though in the end they didn't make
it on screen.
Of course, Cable will be back in the X-Force
movie and, although they're not writing it,
Deadpool 2's screenwriters say we'll likely
hear more in that film about things like the
techno-organic virus that Cable has in the
comics.
Also, according to plot leaks, Deadpool 2
originally included a scene of Cable breaking
into a government facility to steal the time
travel device he uses to go back to find the
young Firefist.
Of course, in the final film, he already has
that device when we first see him in the ruins
of his former home.
As I mentioned earlier, it's becoming more
normal for major movies like Deadpool 2 and
Avengers Infinity War to use fake scenes or
alternate takes in their marketing to avoid
spoilers.
In a comedy like Deadpool, tons of stuff was
improvised in addition to the script, with
Ryan Reynolds delivering multiple riffs on
scenes, which means there were just too many
jokes to fit in the film, so director David
Leitch deliberately included some of those
alternate versions in marketing materials
while others may appear on the Blu-ray.
And to give you a taste of what that included,
here's a stack of alternate and deleted lines
and moments from the Deadpool 2 trailers which
ended up different in the final film.
"Oh, you're living the dream DP."
"Yeah."
"Devil may care attitude."
"Strong thighs."
"Beautiful girlfriend."
"Sorry I'm late."
"I was rounding up all the gluten in the world
and launching it into space where it can't
not hurt us ever again."
"Move or die!"
"Pump the hate brakes Thanos!"
"We're gonna form a super duper f****** group!"
"It's certainly not very cinematic!"
"You're absolutely right."
"Now, let's go get our f*** on!"
"Ooh!
Yeah!
Your bullets ... are really fast."
"Yeah!
Oh!
This is what happens when you turn 40."
"Your time's up you dumb f***!"
"And that is why Sisterhood of the Travelling
Pants is pure pornography."
"Ahhh."
"God, I wish I finished college."
I think some of those trailer lines were funnier
than their counterparts in the movie, though
others in the film were funnier than in the
trailers especially as I wasn't expecting
them, for example, "Pump the hate brakes,
Fox and Friends".
It's a tricky balance for studios as some
fans might appreciate the pleasant surprise
of the final movie ending up a bit different,
while others might feel cheated of moments
they enjoyed in the trailers.
By the way, there was also a joke by Peter
teased in a TV spot that never made it into
the final cut.
"I have both type 1 and 2 diabetes."
"As it turns out we are looking for someone
with diabetes."
"Peter's your man!"
That line was likely ad-libbed by Rob Delaney
who did a lot of improvisation in his role
as Peter.
By the way, originally, the filmmakers toyed
with the idea of one of the screenwriters
playing the part of Peter, but Ryan Reynolds
recommended Catastrophe star Delaney.
And while we did get some amusing shots of
Wade scooting around the X-Mansion in Professor
X's wheelchair, this one of him spinning around
in front of a couple of portraits of Abraham
Lincoln and Barrack Obama didn't make it into
the movie.
There's an example of something being digitally
altered between the trailer and the final
film in the propaganda posters behind Firefist
which changed from "The End Is Near" in the
trailer to "M-Day Is Here" in the movie, which
is a very interesting X-Men easter egg you
can learn more about in my easter egg video.
The Deadpool sequel certainly isn't short
on post-credits scenes as it is; however,
they also filmed an extra credits scene featuring
baby Hitler which was initially going to appear
at the very end of the movie.
The scene was set in a newborn nursery and
showed Deadpool deliberating over whether
to kill the baby lying in a crib.
He eventually decided in favour, saying 'Maximum
effort' as he went in to strangle the infant.
The scene was deleted after it left test audiences
decidedly uneasy, so it seems infanticide
was a step too far even for the notoriously
near-the-knuckle comic-book character.
According to the screenwriters, there was
also another version drafted of that scene
which included Deadpool using a pen to draw
a moustache on the baby so he looked more
like adult Hitler before dispatching him!
By the way, it seems the filmmakers couldn't
entirely resist including a baby Hitler line
in the film.
Deadpool asks Cable why he didn't just travel
back to when Firefist was a baby and kill
him then, "or better yet, head back a little
further, kill baby Hitler."
While the baby Hitler end-credits scene was
actually filmed, another idea the writers
had for the post-credits didn't make it past
the writing stage.
Basically, it was going to involve more X-Force
interviews, one of them with actor Chris Evans
reprising his role as the Human Torch from
Fox's original Fantastic Four movies.
Sadly, they never got as far as actually asking
Evans, who's now best known as the MCU's Captain
America.
However, the reason they didn't end up with
the Human Torch post-credits is that Ryan
Reynolds came up with the idea for the Green
Lantern scene which closes the movie with
Deadpool travelling back in time to shoot
Reynolds who thinks he's made it to the big
time after he gets the script for the much-maligned
DC movie.
Deadpool 2 includes plenty of easter eggs
and jokey references to movies owned by Disney.
However, Ryan Reynolds has said that Fox made
him delete one particular Disney-related joke
from the film.
Cutting the gag was a "sore spot" for Reynolds,
but while he wouldn't reveal what the joke
was, he did tell EW that looking back, removing
it was "a wise decision".
Of course, much of Fox has now been bought
by Disney whose CEO has previously said there
could be room for the R-rated Merc on their
future slate.
However, the merger deal isn't officially
closed yet and it seems it may have affected
the virtually-filter-free Deadpool franchise
which normally takes aim at pretty much everything.
Given the humour in the Deadpool movies, you
can imagine the kind of innuendo the writers
might have come up with for a joke about Fox
and the Mouse House getting together.
But as the "not-safe-for-work" joke was a
bit "too dark" and "at the expense of Disney",
we may never find out exactly what we're missing.
An underwater scene with Deadpool and Vanessa,
who's played by Morena Baccarin, was also
chopped from the movie.
The scene in question was a dream sequence
and filming for it involved an apartment set
being sunk 20 feet under water and Baccarin
being strapped to a chair with weights attached
to her so she stayed in place!
Baccarin was actually pretty annoyed it ended
up cut as she had to confront her massive
fear of being underwater both during the shoot
and during the scuba training to prepare for
it.
However, as she told GMA, unlike Ryan Reynolds
who seemed completely at ease filming the
scene, she found it hard to relax and thinks
her anxiety may have been picked up on camera,
which could be why the scene was deleted.
It sounds like this sequence was how the film
was originally going to depict Vanessa's scenes
with Deadpool in the afterlife.
Instead, in the final film, the afterlife
scenes look like they maybe take some inspiration
from the music video for A-Ha's Take On Me,
which also plays during those scenes.
An alternate early version of the script had
Vanessa leaving Wade and him trying to get
her back.
However, for the screenwriters, Deadpool works
best when he's suffering and has nothing,
so they killed off her character instead.
In the comics, Vanessa is a mutant shape-shifter
known as Copycat and has a much more interesting
role compared to her part in both Deadpool
movies so far.
And considering it's such a self-aware comic-book
movie, the writers' storytelling choice makes
Deadpool 2 less subversive than it likes to
think it is.
Over the years, killing off female characters
merely to motivate male characters and advance
their comic-book stories has been criticised,
with the term "women in refrigerators" or
"fridging" being coined to describe this trope
because women have literally been murdered
and stuffed in a fridge.
To quote Deadpool.
"That's just lazy writing."
And it's especially frustrating that the screenwriters
decided not to develop Vanessa's character
and mutant powers for the sequel as, after
the first movie, they actually said they wanted
to explore that in future films.
It's also interesting that after the writer's
decided to kill Vanessa off, their original
plan was for her to stay dead, and that's
exactly what audiences saw happen at the first
screenings of the film, which didn't include
any time-travelling post-credits scenes as
they hadn't come up with the idea at that
point.
The end-credits scenes were actually filmed
during additional photography.
Speaking of extra filming, as is the case
with most major movies, Deadpool 2 did do
some reshoots and, in March this year, there
were reports claiming the movie was suffering
from poor test screenings.
After the rumours surfaced, counter-reports
appeared in the press, possibly leaked by
the studio, about three separate sets of test
screenings of Deadpool 2, all of which scored
very highly.
Exactly what went on there isn't totally clear
and the official line is that reshoots were
mostly to add more scenes with the two characters
- Cable and Domino - which test audiences
really liked.
But I wonder whether the eventual idea to
resurrect Vanessa also came about because
of reactions from those screenings.
Obviously, test screenings are confidential
so there's no way of truly knowing for sure
whether claims about good or bad tests can
be fully trusted.
At end of Deadpool 2, there's a credit that
reads "IN MEMORY OF SEQUANA HARRIS", in honour
of the stuntwoman and pro racer who died in
a motorcycle accident on the set of the movie
in Vancouver.
At the time of the tragic event, Harris was
doubling for Zazie Beetz in what appears to
have been an action scene of Domino on a motorbike,
and, for obvious reasons, the filmmakers opted
not to reshoot the scene for the final film.
One new character we only saw a little of
in Deadpool 2 was Black Tom Cassidy.
Originally, he was going to have a much bigger
part in the movie, acting as a kind of devil
figure whispering in Russell's ear, pushing
him to criminality.
Comic book fans will know Black Tom as an
X-Men villain and a mutant who can use plant
life to project and manipulate energy.
There are some crazy comic book storylines
with the character and the original idea for
Deadpool 2 was for Black Tom to be the main
villain of the movie.
Speaking to CBR, the writers said there was
a scene planned where Black Tom would create
hailstorms of wood from trees and also move
the entire orphanage.
The idea was scrapped though because the cost
of those CG scenes was too high for the budget,
and the filmmakers decided to focus the CG
money instead on Juggernaut.
So, that's why ultimately Black Tom Cassidy's
role was cut back and the character was quickly
killed off.
The writers have said they regret this a little,
but added that they can always use the time
travel device to resurrect him if they want
to.
There's also a joke about a Deadpool 3 movie
which feels like it might have been filmed
specifically for the trailer, but it probably
could also have worked as one of the motormouthed
merc's many meta-moments within the movie.
"It lives up to the hype.
Plus, plus."
"F*** it, they probably won't make it three."
"Yeah, why would they?"
"Stop at two.
You killed it."
If you're hoping all these deleted scenes
may mean there's a possible extended cut in
the works, then you're likely in luck as director
David Leitch told website Bloody Disgusting
that he hopes to share some lengthier scenes
when the Blu-ray release comes out.
One particular extended scene that Leitch
teased happens in the opening fight montage
and is "a single shot in the bathhouse fight
with the yakuza" which he describes as "a
seamless 360 shot that's really fun".
Something the screenwriters have said will
be on the DVD is a montage of Wade's various
attempts to kill himself after Vanessa's death.
Because of Deadpool's healing factor, each
attempt fails, of course, but in the extended
scene we see Wade making more and more violent
attempts such as jumping into a polar bear
enclosure and swallowing drain cleaner chemicals.
Zazie Beetz also told Digital Spy about a
very funny "back-and-forth" scene between
her and Ryan Reynolds which "everybody loved
[…] – but then parts of the script got
reworked, and so it just didn't fit in anymore."
So, it looks like there's plenty of scope
for bonus Domino and Deadpool deleted scenes
on the Blu-ray!
Now, which scenes do you wish had been included
in the movie?
And do you think it's a good idea filming
fake trailer scenes for big movies like Deadpool
2 and Infinity War?
Be sure to comment and subscribe for a chance
to win this awesome Deadpool merch.
And if you haven't seen my Deadpool 2 easter
eggs video yet, check that out by tapping
left; or tap right for my full deleted scenes
playlist for Marvel movies including Infinity
War, Black Panther, and Thor: Ragnarok.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!